on this week's show how to find your
goldmine area in the news labor
announced a new progressive property tax
Andrew good answering all your property
related questions
welcome to the property investors
podcast thanks so much for tuning in
make sure you subscribe so you never
miss an upload you can catch us on Apple
podcasts Spotify and YouTube enjoy this
week's show and don't forget to share it
with all your friends hi I'm Russell
lead I'm Alistair Cunningham and welcome
to this week's property investors
podcast we've got a really good show
lined up we're going to be talking about
how you can find your goldmine area so
that good places to buy your property
and we'll also be talking about a very
interesting article labour introducing
this new property tax which i think is
prettier
well we haven't we talked about it yeah
but it's been pretty interesting when we
did it me a great show but first of all
have you been buddy a good week I have
an awesome week amazing I've been in
London all day today I am chilling out
enjoying the sights yeah really caught
myself that sounds that sounds brilliant
what science have you seen Tower Bridge
the Thames Talbot we'll see everything
very well obviously filming this live so
if you realize annoyingly I'm so pissed
off that these are closed yeah I must
have you is you guys won't ever say it
you watching at home but the view is
incredible if you've been here honestly
is awesome you can literally see
everywhere and when we were talking
about investing earlier it we had a
little networking session and I saved
someone okay so where do you invest and
they be able to show me let's go come
over here over there is will it shore
over there two or three people as you
are pointing out we can see that much of
of London right it is 25th floor so you
get a really good view of the area but
have you ever realized the Thames were
so dirty it's not from here now you
can't see from here but when we look at
the from here you saw the Thames it was
that bad you've been serious a lot it's
literally just there yeah but you can't
let's do it from here well you can tell
us of discolored let's stay a bit man
really yeah I'm sure it is filthy I'm
sure there is some nice M rat
Sylla yeah probably a few other things
in there as well to be honest my body's
thanks Rob I bet there is some it's
somewhere in the Thames as bodies maybe
for money like what you're saying yeah
I'm not freaking it's cuz they're from
London they know what happens really
body of course man so what if you
Bentley them I've literally traveled
here I can get to central London in an
hour on the train from it's real yeah
you drove didn't you took me four hours
yeah and then I didn't have time to go
to my hotel so I had to come straight
here because the hotels is that well
you're not dressed properly yeah pretty
much
okay so let's let's get let's get
cracking how to find your gold mine area
so I suppose first of all the question
you gotta ask yourself you looking for a
gold mine area is what sort of
strategies it will depend apps what sort
of strategy you gonna be should we
should we just pick one strategy for 10
B okay well what you want to pick HMOs
okay so you want to buy HMOs yeah what's
your first tip on how to find a good
area how to find a gold mine pattern
image most okay so HMO is the first
thing you need to know is that it will
work I hate you more probably will work
in that area so you need to know as
demand for rooms you need to know that
there is not an oversaturation of
current HMOs
okay so for instance I literally shared
rowlandson min ago and I've got Haiti
more in Hull which is generally seen as
a little bit of an oversaturated area my
property went live literally we were
thirsty when live a Monday and I had
four tenants by Wednesday I just got the
phone call today that they're all signed
up yesterday and they're due to move in
two on Friday to next Monday you had
four tenants in two days yep and they're
paying pretty much full market rent so
thoroughly must formal well what
fourteen hundred for the property but
it's actually getting about thirteen
sixty so I'm happy with that
yeah and but I didn't buy that property
that's the lease option property so one
of those bloody free house he's only
bringing you in thirteen sixty you know
it's funny cuz full more fourteen
hundred it is funny because they do you
know we I see this all the time on on
like YouTube and people making comments
about how you lease options aren't
possible and you can't do lease options
and
they don't work that was so David Brent
somebody else said that they're not even
friends people say to me also on YouTube
you know police officers don't work well
I'm Alison I've got multiple attends it
so don't tell me the work and don't tell
me you can't do them we've used a little
money cuz I've done it a little money I
won't tell the the the one in Hull was
literally 750 pound plus legals and that
was how much it cost me to get the keys
so it's crazy isn't it
normally I wouldn't do this but as we
have a live audience I think he deserves
a hand oh yeah so I wouldn't know it'll
just be me and Nick be like be a bit
craps so okay how do we find that the
first thing you mentioned was you need
to find an area that works yeah so how
do you how do you pick an area how do
you find an area that you know is gonna
work you see I just said oversaturated
yet you still rented it out in like two
days
yeah so how do you how do you know that
women area is gonna work or not
okay so the first thing I would do is I
would always try and stay to like a
large town or a city ideally a
university city or things that I've got
things that cities are got things going
on so like rather than all those cities
they've got anything going up there's
places up north me with a so there's
nothing going on like Blackpool sorry
Glen
there is places where there's just not a
lot of activity there's no jobs as
there's not a lot of industry yeah so a
big safe bustling say a lot of things
we've been businesses etc cities that
have got training hospitals are good as
well as they have a lot of tunnel we're
managing a lot of properties in
Wolverhampton and Warsaw and the ones
that were near the hospitals just they
would go like do you know interestingly
like both both my lease option HMOs they
were both filled up within two weeks
like and they're neo universities the
near hospitals in New York City Center
so ok so you pick an area big town big
city whatever it is it's bustling got a
lot of people you know got a look and
see what you think it's gonna work so
and also there has to be a supply of
property in that area that will be
suitable for HMOs well that's the next
thing once you've found a good area then
you need to test the ROI right yeah area
first
you found the area you go on places like
spare room yeah and you have a look and
you see what see what how much they're
rented out for how much rooms are rented
out for and how much you can buy a
property for if the if the properties
are like like Samuel has a route like
are a rule of thumb it's not set in
stone 25 to 30 thousand pound pair
electable room so if the properties 300
thousand points are for bed ain't really
gonna work so you've got a supply of
property around about hundred K it's all
about the ROI yeah so if you're spending
forty thousand banner room yeah but
you're getting good was very investment
it doesn't matter yeah okay so if you
spent a 4k per room yeah properties
typically what 160-200
yeah but you could buy two properties
100k and out of eight rooms true true
that much come back for that that is
true but what I'm talking about if
you've got a good return on investment
so therefore say for example let's say
you bought one for 120 okay I suppose
this begs the question how about three
bed HMOs and stuff like that but let's
say you bought on for 120 that gave you
a good ROI on a three bed yeah does it
matter that it's only with 40 grand a
room it doesn't does it it doesn't
matter but we did not be better to
diversify a little bit I think it would
I have less risk I would rather have
engines ready
not a big risk is it surely it's some
people who thinks hundred twenty
thousand pounds a big risk
so at moneybags you don't put in a
hundred twenty grand right so look if
you're going to spend like forty fifty
thousand pound on a property you could
easily get two or three plot like two
not three but you could get two
properties sure
like the certain places in the country
like Liverpool you so what's the
advantage you're getting two properties
over one property because you have more
rooms that's more risks or the ROI is
the same was the event we just talked
about ROI so you doing all right yeah so
what's the what's the advantage arriving
to over one because if you think about
it all right point of view is not
because there's no you also means you've
got double the work to manage two
properties
why have we got double the work well
it's not it's not how many properties do
you have it Russell I know I know I know
how you can answer this question you
have properties yeah do you do the work
believe me right believe me now okay
he's getting stressed I'm not getting
stressed I'm going stressed you're not
gonna make it me in an argument right
right here's the thing you don't tell me
that you don't do any work on your
properties at all even if it's just
managing the managers yeah I do it
absolutely but it's minimal it's minimal
I actually do you know when I first got
involved
I was very hands-on and you know was
cause like I was I was title and who I
told you well and you had to go up me
about it he said what you doing man and
then I very quickly learnt to get hit
your mom I just do that all over the
hedge realm and you've still got a step
in at times yeah but it's minimal yeah I
think I would rile up okay come on now
get that ROI point of view it makes no
difference because the money in money
out and but from a risk point of view I
would rather have 810 it's been aided in
rents than 410 is pin rent because if
two tenants not paying rent in the four
properties and therefore the four rooms
you only get to read truth it's just but
again I was gonna say depends on the
area so yeah two properties in a bit of
a crap area but that you bought one and
error is going up who knows but anyway
it's more about your ROI but okay 25 30
grand
berming was a bit more expensive well
we've got some now over areas are a bit
cheaper so you find an area you go on
spare room you check and you look at and
one of the things that salmon always
talks about the crash course is when you
look on spare room you've got two
different types of outs you've got
people that are advertising properties
yeah and then you've got people that are
advertising themselves yes but we are is
a bit weird and people always say oh
there's more properties than there are
people looking but the thing you gotta
remember is that everyone puts their
property on whereas most people that are
looking for property don't put
themselves on someone they just go and
look at the properties like more sane
people do yeah most sane people do so
you can't you can't judge eternity by
that but you can get an idea do you know
what I like about spare room is it lists
a lot of hate your mall managers because
they're generally advertising the rooms
so you can ring them on and they don't
sometimes if you like Google hate you
more managers in a specific area you do
not advertise them mm-hmm but you find
them on spare room and open rent and
things like and the thing is they're
also very honest because they don't want
a property that they can't rent out
exactly because it's just hassle if
someone has managed loads of HMOs I
certainly didn't want anyone any and
that's their brand-new we're just
desperate for business yeah anyone
that's been established a bit they will
be honest with you about the area where
works whether it's saturated or not the
type of rent you'll get so ringing those
so do bit do blow bare due diligence you
know in Hull I've found the hateem all
managers are actually turning a lot
people away because they're saying look
we want to look at your property forest
and then even they come out and look at
it and they're like no it's rubbish
we're not gonna rent it we're not even
interest and put on our books yeah so
they're making them very high standard
and that's where and they'll be like oh
it's on that street no yeah exactly they
know the streets at work they know what
works so and they also know what rains
so quickly and that's why I think
there's a lot of people a lot people say
HMOs don't work right they do there's
lots people say it online and see HMOs
don't work they don't fill the rooms up
things are the reality is when you start
looking at the property that they're
trying to rent out I wouldn't live there
like would you look like some of them
were just discussin over you wouldn't've
a nice rifle stock yeah but if it was I
wouldn't live in some of these million
rooms and like they've got dirty
furniture like it's just disgusting and
I have looked at hundreds and hundreds
of HMOs and many of them are
and they're absolutely grim and I'm like
no wonder this place will not rent out
so this is true like my property in
Wolverhampton I was as well talking this
actually on the podcast we filmed
yesterday but I'll just quickly share
and the landlord when I was agree in the
terms on the lease auction the landlord
said to me you'll never get more than
six hundred pound for this property and
I'm at okay thank thank you for sharing
just I'm happy to take that risk and
then he said you're crazy you're gonna
regret this
that property rents out for sixteen
hundred pound because I put a little bit
of a friend time into enough mediate
immaculate and he didn't he wasn't
prepared to do that
and my my time and effort to make it
immaculate cost 4,000 pounds so I had
three months that I've got that back so
the ROI and that probably is crazy it's
utter crazy that was a lease option as
well at least option yes and I can and
interestingly I can buy it in five years
and it's already worth what I would be
divided in five years for so that's
that's the second - that's enough claps
for in their lease option you want
clapping for I have actually will say
that Nora day and okay so they've got to
get supply of properties in area and
reasonably priced properties that so I
pick an area that's reasonably cheap to
buy yeah look at thirty five thirty
thirty-five grand per room
Valletta ballroom then go on spare room
bring the managers have a look what the
demands like to see I personally
wouldn't just ring the manager so that
when you're picking your Goldman area
you want your gold many o to be your
area you should know that inside out so
you summer talks about big days get out
there boots on ground get out there on
go into the agents actually won't sit
down with them and you'll find if you
make the effort to go and actually sit
down in front of an estate a late an
agent they all have a lot more time for
you if you just ring them up guess what
you're just another random calling them
up asking for free advice and what
happens when you ring us for free advice
I say watch the podcast watch the Pope
has a question on there
yeah and I'll maybe answer it yeah but
it's been very long with them are you
but if you if they take the effort to
actually go into that estate agent and
say look I'm looking to I'm looking at
human area I'm looking for something
manager can you just before make a
Russian so I wanted to get a little bit
advice can you just advise the best
places and also oh and if need be
offered to pay for the time say look
I'll happily pay for an hour of your
time if you can just help me most you
thirty quid or forty quid away about
whatever is it's well worth it
I'd understand Doncaster I went to an
agent in Doncaster and I literally just
walked in and I said to look I'm looking
to buy some properties in the area
I thought about the wrong ones can I
just sit down with you for half an hour
I'm more than happy to cover your course
and pay for your time if you can just
advise me the best places and any I buy
and will happily peruse your services
and they were the most helpful people I
was in if like an hour and a half they
actually took me out and we went looked
at some properties and looked at some
areas and they told me all the gold many
areas in Doncaster all the streets to
buy industries to avoid and that's why
the the last two three problems I bought
and Doncaster for investors for as a
source of business they've rented out
within two weeks that's why because I've
done my due diligence forest I didn't I
didn't rush into a property and then see
ah nobody need to get a late an agent
for it I thought that will be around
yeah and then the other thing you can do
I suppose is once you've highlighted the
areas you can just wait for properties
to come up become a ground if you've
done this in different areas and just
wait for the properties to come up there
might be a street that's a brilliant
streets what nothing for sale right now
what is that what lessons are don't be a
motivated buyer be a patient by on yeah
properties a long game you've got being
longing don't rush oh and just buy a
house because you're desperate to get
one in you called my patch yeah you can
even a set up like right move alerts
couldn't allowance you know the areas
that are gonna work well have you look
me through as soon as one comes up in
that area yeah bang you get an email
come through yeah you can set the you
can set the price and rooms and also
right move it's about six months cool
they added our key feature key word form
up and run and hit your mall so ideally
like do you know if you're looking for
your gold my pad and there's up and
running HMOs in there there for sale
there are a bit run down there
the good ones to buy especially once
you've confirmed by Alene agent little
walk yeah
so that's step three make sure there's a
supply of property and you split a Lane
agent yeah hope you step forward step
forward to work out your ROI all right
how much is it gonna cost how much
you're gonna get out of it and make sure
it's snappy you want to be looking at
20% plus I think so yeah I think so yeah
you know there's no point doing it for
less than that there's not but I do have
I've got a massive list of investors
overseas all over the place and I've got
investors are very happy with 10% there
also but when it's very easy to make 20
why would you make ten you made ten yeah
so I would I would add a fifth state to
this we have a power team you need to
know that in your area you've got a good
power team or you've got access to two
people they can assist if you did any
refurb because we don't always want to
be doing the work yourself so as a
company we've we've built a network of
builders contractors all sorts plumbers
electricians whatever yeah well don't
mean to share how I've done that do you
want me to show up than that I don't ok
can you keep it quiet
you have to don't don't promise it
doesn't leave this room it's all right
you're letting agent that's all I need
to say you're letting agent has a list
of all these people a list of people
that they are trusted that they are
cheap and they're they've done plenty of
work for the lenten agent and they're
not gonna let you down the letting agent
is your best your best source and supply
of tradesmen that's it you heard it here
first
so what about step 7
are you just adding steps now yeah why
not we keep doing it ok step 7
can I can I add one thing unless you
know it unless you know you know you
know right ok go and visit the area and
go and visit the area at night kind of
mention that we thought um night though
we didn't mention no come visit night ok
case in point I I saw the property to an
investor and he did go and visit it at
night and realized there was a quite a
few unsavory people hanging around near
the property and that things did he say
hi do you know pick me off out in the
area I would always just Alex the
Alistair's excuse for going around like
if he ever gets caught I did say I hang
around
dodgy areas that no yeah thanks man and
yeah just them I would go up there look
at night make sure see what's going on
and I because a lot of so what's the
best story if you've had when you've
done this was the best thing you've seen
there's two oh this wasn't yeah I saw
the property to an investor it was on a
road called Chumley Street it's in he to
three really nice house really nice
house and but at the end of the house is
a drive and that's the este so it's the
ain't terrace and there's a nice drive
and my investor turned up to look at
their house and he found a woman passed
out drunk middle of day in the front
hanging off the wall turns out sheets
like she was a bit local drug dealer
a local drug a drug addict and he pulled
her at the property he said he don't
want to do anymore
because she was like she'd sort lane
against the wall and she's passed out
she was covered in sick and a lot I was
in his front garden so yeah his new
house this is the house I recommend you
buy he for me he did for an ambulance
but and he wronged me up he was aleister
that hazardous bought from you I've just
found that a drug addict and a drug
addict in the front guard and I think
you may have to find me another one and
then okay all right can't argue with
that really so I'm guessing the other
ones worse I'm not going to tell the
owner because it involves some did it
right okay okay so it's in Wolverhampton
it was at my HMO okay turns I was in the
right red-light district and so we a
couple of us were actually out mover
Hampton one night
and then my hate remote was finished
Philly Forester Mike is already go so we
just decided to stay there one night
instead of picking hotel and as we were
all walking back from the the town at
like two o'clock in the mornin there was
more prostitutes and I've ever seen in
my life and then we all got
propositioned and I'm happy to Amsterdam
oh yeah oh yeah I've been Tamsin there's
more in Wolverhampton yes and yeah yeah
and they were like literally hanging
outside the front lads just probably 20
30 yards that way because we're right at
the very end of the street and it's they
can own area for them but do you know
what I don't care cuz it rents out I
don't care but see some investors do
because some in bases get emotionally a
tight emotionally type things hold on
Oh what I don't get about that story is
yeah like why did you don't want to name
the person because I've not told the
full story and
I knew there was more Wow just because I
he's a student and he got offered
student discount in all sports do you
have to show us code he asked and we
were only playing games with them but
yes and she said yeah Aldous shouldn't
disco but they dress the thing there's a
key lesson here don't get emotionally
tied to the property buying it's an
investment doesn't matter what's going
on there as long as it doesn't as long
as the tenants are happy look that yes
well you said we were playing games with
them not like that as if we were walking
past and they were trying to prove
proposition ours and we were just having
a laugh and then we just continue
walking okay okay cool not like that
so go lay at night 2 a.m. what's the
perfect time I've never been there again
since Justin see what's going on nearby
I see mother I know some day they went
it's literally parked outside is hit you
more and stayed there's like five hours
just to see what's going on see you see
if if there's people I know sorta that
was selling a house and the people that
were borrowing it said to them listen we
want a quiet house is it quiet and they
said yeah it's quiet
okay can we come round yeah one even in
and just sit in your lounge just make
sure that it is quiet and they were like
okay yeah sure and they just came out
they just sat there all evening and then
they were like interesting yeah it's
quite enough and they left
that's not clearly not an investment
property that's a property a home yeah
so that's opposite bit more important
cuz nobody wants to live in a noisy home
we know as a neighbor so I get that as
an investment property yeah as long as
the property has good demand and will
rent out and the final thing that I
would say is well if funny gold mine not
really got mine area but what would you
look for if you buy it because it's all
my hmm is what would you look for in a
house to make sure that it's a good you
know it's a good gonna be a good I've
suddenly lost the ability to speak which
is bad because there's a podcast but I
really have what do you look for in a
house to make sure that it's gonna be a
good hmm
you mean condition-wise or Leo or an
dude everything okay so we always try
and walk before bedrooms
the reason being is three bedrooms I
don't thinks enough and typically the
reason being is because if you see a
four-bedroom property yeah approximate
one week we'll pay your your mortgage or
your lease option or whatever one week's
rent that is and another weeks rent will
pay the bills
that leaves two full rents which is
profit one week's rent no one want one
room no no I'm sorry Saul said typically
I hate you more about forty five percent
of the income goes out to expenses and
quarters mortgages and things are so you
make a sort of fifty before if I do lose
25% yeah and then if you have 110 and if
you have a void period summarize just a
little bit hard on a three bed and so I
would always go I wouldn't do a three
bed and four is ideal because we're far
if you need the lies yeah okay but I
don't like five that's what I say I
would rather go six yeah so I would
rather be four or six or seven I agree
who's five it's just not worth that
extra all the extra hassle so six is
four six four six but you know a good
five told you up and running slightly
different but wouldn't compare if you're
going to go to all the airflow and money
of converting a normal sort of a five I
guess you looking for four little rooms
and bi-level room it needs to be seventy
square feet minimum seventy square feet
however that does vary slightly if you
put on Suites in though and but all I
would do is you're a gold mine patch you
need to know the rules and who is the
best source of rules and that gold my
patch council council HMO officer at the
council and actually do you know they're
really helpful they really want to help
you so they're not they're not out to
get you and I have to get you they're
not to try to stitch you up
they're out to help you so if you go to
them forest and say look I'm thinking
about this property again you may have
to pay for their time last time I got
some debt was 95-pound they come out and
they went through the whole property for
me and they are safe
everything and they said look this will
work and it would be good and it would
be very easily get a license sounds
gonna get six better mmm so speak to the
hitch more so you get good results from
that and the other thing is local he
team or manager ask them about the rules
and regulations for an area and also
things like be aware of article 4 if
it's not enforced at present find out
when it's going to be enforced if it's
if the informations available ya know
the government and the council have to
give you 12 months notice before the
enforcer actually we should mention that
really in they're looking for the area
you need to make sure it's not an
article for area yeah because if it is
even if everything else stacks up you've
gotta get planning it's just it's not
worth it's not worth but also with
article 4
there's certain places it's not city
like Wolverhampton City wait right
Walsall there's none they ask there's a
road
some areas have just licked touched like
Liverpool's got like half about 20 rules
Birmingham's got a little bit so don't
just think are to befall I said I'm done
I can't I can't invest in that city
hall's the same holes got a little bit
of article 4 but actually the best
places to get hitch Moore's or I would
say the art before that's why and I
think we've just done it in 12 months
time art force and have been extended to
cover that area I genuinely blame Samuel
for were Hampson's article 4 yeah thanks
I genuinely did yeah because they
literally was just behind them left
right left right and then it suddenly
what they bought particle forward but do
you know what's good with areas they've
got article 4 there's always tired
landlords in there always and they
Wolverhampton got law of up-and-running
HMOs that I just run down landlords want
rid of them and the cheap yeah and it's
a good area to rent out very very
awesome
brilliant well I think we've we've know
what that is now time for this
[Music]
okay so in the news this week it's just
been as Labor's progressive property tax
explained so labor basically proposing a
new property tax and but the levy we
paid by the landlord's rather than the
tenants okay which shocks me I'm gonna
thought labor reduce labor is
considering placing council targets with
a new progressive property tax yes bad
already isn't it that was set nationally
and paid by property owners rather than
the tenants the proposals are part of a
raft of policy recommendations in a
labor commission report on land use the
aim is to reduce the tax paid by the
majority of households and discourage
the the use of homes as financial assets
why the government always trying to
punish landlords who knows always so
yeah I mean so that's kind of the basics
of so basically what the plan will be is
rather than having usual council tax
yeah maybe different scheme where the
homeowner pays the council tax rather
than rather than the tenants which is
just like like you say it's another
thing of the government trying to hit
landlords and it's not gonna hit
landlords is it because what's going to
happen to rent well the rent is going to
go what the landlord's gonna pass it on
to their tenants of course they are I
actually saw don't mind that because if
you don't pick hemsworth Act so let's
just say that some tenants have a habit
of not paying council tax
now we we're actually I was having a
meeting birthday with a bailiff this is
true not it wasn't after me you know to
my dorm we had a little chat no no I was
I having a meeting with a bailiff
holiday and the biggest collection they
do is for council tax it's for people
that were in council tax arrears and
that's where tenants officer not be no
cancer tax now the properties get a
black mark in sameen and who suffers
from that the property owner have you
ever suffered from that no has anyone
here ever suffered from that sound like
a massive probably no carry on it's a
massive problem because it's I wouldn't
warn my property being blacklisted as
owing council tax is that you sure about
that
not an official thing but it does Dave I
wouldn't want I wouldn't want that tag
so the if the tenants are not paying the
council tax that's correct
it may not be but I just still wouldn't
want just wouldn't wanna and I wouldn't
want it I wouldn't want my property had
been in some sort of blacklist whatever
as owing council tax because sometimes
it's you talk of thousands and thousands
of pounds and the problem is if that
tenant then leaves the day is always is
with it it's with a tenant but it's also
with the property now isn't it will
still come to that property they won't
I couldn't just bail if there was still
comfort property yeah but it could still
cause problems for the people that move
they move into it bailiffs knock on the
door and it's not nice interesting yeah
I just had a letter come to the door cuz
I wasn't paying my council tax that's
why it that Luke C that's right because
I'd moved house yeah and I've forgotten
to let that is the same counsel I've
forgotten to counsel the one and and and
say it if on the other on the around
Europe a bit of a nightmare for not
changing addresses a I'm not very
organized when it comes to stuff hmm so
so yes so they wrote me off well add
this letter through and because I've
been away a lot been traveling a lot
I'm open the boast about we have you
been traveling what you mean well we
have you been traveling we were doing
events all the time in abroad on on so
you lost your passport
I said that is a true story I was meant
to go when I was there last week and
even we agreed to meet at the airport at
3:00 we're going we're going to
Barcelona and I rang you at 1:00 I was
like I can't off my passport I'm sure I
find it but and then I couldn't go cost
me thousands but whatever yeah I'm not
very good at stuff remember so yeah so I
rang them up I got like a court date
come through for it for me I was I was
all I'm really sorry I actually have
been paying it just tore the wrong house
and they were like oh yeah and they just
change over it was fine but what my
point is is that they came after me and
what happened was they originally went
after the old tenant and they will oh no
it's Russell Leeds that lives there now
and then they came after me and he
wasn't after the house it was definitely
after after me
yeah I mean that the bailiff that's not
what he that yeah but how are they after
you ah they'll always keep coming back
to the house until you can prove you
there yeah sure let me tell you why
you're wrong because you said the only
thing will change is your calling right
now
which is true yeah new donald's will do
that however generally or there's
annoying tenants that doesn't pay
suddenly you're now losing your rent and
you're having to pay out you know money
for you council tax it does seem that no
matter what happens the the government
are trying to always find a stake to
batter tenare landlords yeah always
trying to find that sticking together
and bigger over time so I think it's
great but let's just let's just hope
that he doesn't it doesn't come in but
there you go that I don't know what your
thoughts are if you've got thoughts
please comment you watch this on youtube
please comment below let us know what
what you think of this or if you got any
more in sciences but the depressing us
like the news in general is not so users
terrible it's always depress spirits now
with this
[Music]
right since now time for the questions
and answers unlike usual we're not going
to be a reason them from our phone to
get me ask you have beautiful live
audience that are here with us today so
does anyone have a question yes stand up
please
so we're trying a stack a deal I want
this answer for HMO and the service
accommodation I only get your money for
yeah exactly
what kind of pricey looking at - reefer
this so come on HMO prospective how much
pop a bed a wardrobe drawers curtains
and things like that mark show you how
much do you do associate in your head
where you're looking at people at the
same other service foundation as well so
obviously there's a little bit working
and stuff associated as well so what
kind of look as you are you based on to
do what more figure in there
can I go with this I've done this max I
I'm gonna have to have my back - yeah
sorry love you man
all right listen um I've just done it by
for bed hate you more in hole it costs
just under five thousand pound to fully
furnished that place dress the place and
that's including all the cutlery bedding
things I can almost like towel holders
do you know all the celery like that
finishing touches
yeah you know and I have no idea like
shays light shades do you know everyone
forgets like Jim's it's true and zero
five ever made I mean like if you've
your budget in the world know it's not
the end of world but everyone forgets
some people forget cut the free when
they didn't hit yours and the only put
like two like the bare minimum of plates
and always put doubles but yeah about
five grand for a hmm a for bed hit Jamal
every room is approximately five five
five hundred six hundred pound depending
on what quality furniture you're going
for and I wouldn't be buying your
furniture lease it it's the most
tax-efficient way to do it so don't buy
Lisa because then you can have it as an
expense Gingin only companies that offer
leasing furniture absolutely
so better source we do this we do this
on a day-to-day basis we have a guy that
specializes in furnishing and dressen
properties and service accommodation
is around about the same but it depends
how many bedrooms are is so again go by
the go by the five to six huh go by the
five to six hundred pound and pair room
and but it depends how high-end you want
to go oh I think those combinations I
was going to say is a bit is very
different actually yeah because it could
be a one-bedroom apartment yeah it could
be an 8 bedroom you know yeah B&B start
so how can you engage that so they
should see its I don't know a to bed
apartment what what I would say is that
service for me if service combination
you want to be higher end yes then you
hate your mo you want to look nicer you
want to have things like light shades
and things like that you know you know
do you know with a HMO you want hard
wearing everything hardware and
furniture hardware their heads and
actually in service accommodation you
want hardware in bands as well I got you
know my service combination was up for a
month and they brought two of the beds
man say I don't know what they were
doing
I'm sorry I was a hue you did stay there
actually know when I stood when I said
they was already broken I can assure you
yeah so yeah man oh man such a question
just glad command your hand is the
highest please stand up and it was
waving so that's good hand
hi I am waving hello hello my shock if
you have a compliance meant business yes
and you find a lot of deals the New York
scene perhaps hot horse take them all on
yourself
so you want to sell it on a console do
you need to have a separate sourcing
company or can can you already as a
compliant when to enter just sell that
one and not have to have no Canada
because the compliance is different for
each company so you have to have a
separate company sale for a sourcing so
the compliance for rent event is not the
same as compliance for deal sources but
could you ever come and it was compliant
for both you could yeah you could but
you have to have additional compliance
so the question was you've got a
compliant rent during business and but
that's not that doesn't mean it's
compliant for deal sources so you don't
add things to it
well then I think you do on to companies
don't tell you why if you sell a deal
and it goes terribly wrong and they sue
you or something you don't want to take
down your rent to rent business at the
same time so you want to keep those ways
a little wiser limited company limit so
you want to keep them you want to keep
them separate yeah I would always keep
it separate yeah always that means
learning to you know but if you're gonna
do two things you need to learn two
things of course I'm not saying that but
if you're going if you're really
focusing on one strategy it's taking
your time to learn that when you're
seeing all these deals maybe people want
obviate to then go and be an actual deal
source own and be someone who's good at
that cowboy I'm sorry you're gonna have
to do probably there's no two ways about
it
if you want to do it do it properly
there's too many cowboy deal sources in
the country and I don't want you to
become one of them please don't and so
just do it properly from the offset if
you do probably you've got nothing to
worry about
but the fact that you're asking these
questions and the way the way that
you're conducting yeah I would know that
that you would do that you know about it
so yeah so just just do it gets to
companies if you want or just think you
know what it's not worth thinkin of a
company to make the odds
two and a half grams how many are you
thinking you're gonna sell well it's
really that's because I'm specializing
in men's men's you do see a lot of deals
and being at the beginning they'd say
you find four deals which can happen
you're actually going to pocket a super
lot of offers on the table happy days
for people to come back to you
don't have the finances to those small
deal yeah I was thinking you know
there's a lot people
they love you but I don't necessarily
want to be setting up some business at
the same time you some advice no I'm
over the last few years as entrepreneurs
and I'd say most people that here
probably would consider yourself as
entrepreneur yeah yeah
people that want you know what I'm able
to make money as we don't like leaving
money on the table we see opportunities
like this and we're not hard can be
selling these could be doing that and
for me when I started very much that was
the case it was already there someone
did that how I could manage properties I
could do bad I found my back could do
this and yeah but what you actually find
is is that it often helps to focus on
something so firm it I've clerk saw my
companies like we would we had to deal
sourcing company and it was making like
30 grand a month and we just closed it
down because it was taking our time and
energy away from the stuff we actually
wanted to do it was a case of it's not
worth it for us and when we passed all
our leads over to our us there who is
also doing the same thing so sometimes
it is ok to leave money on the table and
sometimes if it's going to distract you
from doing what you actually should be
doing and what your what your mission is
and what your goal is it's best to put
all your focus into that it's not always
the case I'm not the same piece to but
there are times when you want make make
sense to monopolize it but for me quite
often if you're not not sure definitely
but then it's best just to not do it and
just focus on what you want to do does
that make sense
can I just quickly say something as well
so you're moving your main business is
rent to rent why don't you flip it right
and make your main business deals
awesome and then have the rent rent as a
subsidiary from the deal sore zone so
you're out find the rent rent deals
you've said so why don't you set up a
deal source and compliant business
you're out you just said you found four
deals
sell three four to three thousand pounds
keep on yourself two separate companies
but what I would say is you you focus on
the rent to reign in the minute so why
don't you focus on the deal sourcing
because that's going to generate you huh
it's gonna generate more money there's
no two ways about it
I love rent to rent I love rent rent
service accommodation and typically a
rental and service combination might
make you a thousand pound a month and
all those people have their make them
crazy
there's also people up there only making
forward upon a month and average 700,000
casual pepper Olli so it is a little bit
passive but if you go active income and
you sell one deal a month that's free
ground a month it which might want to do
that she might not want what is it what
do you want oh the thing is I actually
to set this business up so as opposed to
even bother with the deal saucy that's
all personally if you live in the
Canaries and you looking for passive
income rent rent if you're looking to
build up a poor money deal source and
then use that money to build passive
income that's exactly what I done I'm so
it just depends what you want out of
this yeah
team up with a deal sorcerer and say hey
I've got these brilliant deals if you
sell them what can you give me it you
know give me a faithful passing them
your way and then blow all the hassle of
comply not sell it just let them sell it
on and let them give you a cup and then
you have the hassle then do you go then
it's just a conversation with a deal
source that you can agree a joint
venture then you I'm gonna do all the
all the crap yeah that's awesome
give her hand
this lady sorry this she was waving her
hands and she was like looked really
energetic so so I can see got your back
- hi thanks Hey and so the only areas I
keep my hands in could you would you be
able to give me six areas that you have
missed six areas that we invested at
what might you currently have invested
in tease me or my investors I deal with
something with thousands of investors or
just any you know six areas that you
think are the best for buying and
renting out okay okay let's go
Doncaster yeah you want to write this
down yeah of course it will be on the
podcast because that's what we're
filming in other words because you just
watch it next week right okay so you
don't have to write it down then
Doncaster Sunderland Games bra Lincoln
Manchester Salford see it's gonna be in
the podcast okay I remember right okay
Gainsborough Lincoln mm-hmm some parts
of press then but various only only some
parts and Liverpool very good
how many about how many Matt okay so
catering Corby Peterborough who's gonna
Bank Colby okay Kobe's good man for HMOs
no because the ROI goes it drops
instantly but there is like some places
right down so I think South Hamilton
places are good some places in Brighton
but the prices you could your are rise
gonna drop so it's all about before
you're comfortable with all right I
probably out to him as well
all right down Wolverhampton hope
did you get home and move hunter okay
that's the question around the guy just
at the very back right in front of you
been my loss and you mentioned having
two companies right one for dual
sourcing and one maybe for property
overall yeah as you said it's best
because if they sue to the ground your
properties don't go yes right now and
the thing is what if you want to get the
sorcerer in order to actually find the
deposit for your property and everything
they don't really how do you transfer
the funds in with our business loans so
you get a loan between companies company
yeah you need to speak to an accountant
and we can't give a countess the advice
bar speak to your accountant because
it's very possible
it's very very possible thank you
the guy just in front of you I thought
you would say we can't you can't see
much but and I was expecting something
but speak to a cowboy we can because we
give you the wrong advice and you go out
and do it I'd rather you can get
professional it's been filmed yeah and
especially cuz I'm not on a counter yes
sir
enjoying it yeah I did yeah come on
buddy said
[Music]
very few people know yeah yeah let's do
it now yeah right right
[Laughter]
[Music]
so so Rossum I am I playing hard to get
or what do you think do you want me to
be an easygoing landlord or hardcore
Nalanda to be easier to get easy or hard
corner what do you guys want hard going
going to be hard
sorry Molly move on come on pick the
phone up really hard to get
he doesn't mean you're not going around
to the phone to it I never answered my
four in the first ring hello just come
across your property on gumtree
Oh Sophie toss a few questions that's
all right
yeah sure okay you've seen on Rightmove
I'm not sure I fall into the rules so
well right start again come on you were
like hello and then he was like really
friendly which I've never done that to
ever be good yeah I got your mantra
right okay why would you come on man
let's go
Gumtree oh that's amazing thanks Bob
okay yeah it's three big terrorist okay
sing good condition no it's
however the back pains it's all done
okay when you say that's the only option
time says okay yeah I keep getting these
people ringing me out like hope for me
like silly bluemark about you no no
nobody I do it okay yeah I'm making cops
come on I'm just looking some Hakka
check me out okay it's a few properties
in the area
is it 70,000 hard just painted money to
give out it okay yeah do my boss you
called a financial question or proxy
yeah I don't get personal
okay so how much you looking to get
those properties around fifty six
thousand I think it's listed for this
will be 17 oh sorry
seventeen thousand is this suitable yeah
okay I do my language is renting out for
her I know I look here sorry I don't
know I'm at the bedside for I'm sorry
okay
what's the motivation just looking to
sell my house I want to move on my wife
cheated on me so I'm just like found
that she was sleeping with my neighbor
so I just you know not really by the way
if you're watching this and I don't want
this Punk anymore
okay and in that case obviously the
money yeah it's not the capital that you
are what you're essentially looking for
work somehow
okay okay well what's the absolute
lowest price that you willing to accept
it swaps any passes are you know what
I'm definitely interested mostly but I
think the market needs some time to
recover so would you be willing to say
I've been waiting to make the punch
punch of price offer it's a five-year
time and in the meantime are you willing
to pay the mortgage papers every month
and
myself as soon as you take the hat off
you for the property
it's a classic lease option agreement
man give it up for this guy that's
that's good that's really good I would
do a bit more I would actually go in
view the property before you do that
script I get in front of the guy and do
a little bit of duty but that was always
pretty awesome but win-win the guy's
just to give that guy the bank back when
when you when you have this conversation
in real genuine lease options are yes
yeah I find the scripts of good they
always worked for me as part of the
script yes I don't I don't think you got
the situation where he where he
exhausted the options of no I was that
you actually might be interested in
doing this yeah if you kind of asked
uncovered the questions but he didn't go
so I think it needs more natural yeah I
think I think you sound I mean might be
that you'd be an all fairness that
you're doing it who Alastair Cunningham
the Alastair coming 150 people getting
filmed in fairness but you sounded to me
a little bit nervous but you know what
was gonna come next so that I would just
say just be like really super relaxed
about it yeah and don't worry too much
about whether you get it or not
yeah you basically all you're trying to
find out if you go with this mindset I
think it makes a big difference don't go
in the mindset of I want to get a lease
option agreement going with the mindset
of I want to find out why they want to
sell their house and if a lease option
is an option then great and so you don't
rush for that point at all you can just
saw some so what what you planning on
doing you're playing on moving on a lot
most people are trying to sell their
house to buy another house Yeah right
I thought most and from your I can tell
where I didn't know what your plan was
but you ain't got there but if they're
doing that there's no point
mentioning a lease option because this
just not gonna work for them so you're
looking for someone who's trying to sell
their house because it was an
inheritance property or because they
bought it as an investment property and
it's not making them any money and they
want to get rid of it or something along
along those lines it's it's really
important that you just focus on
exhausting exhausting the options find
out where they're at find out what they
want it's the first rule of sales isn't
it you need to find out what they want
and then you give it them yeah so just
be really super relaxed about it don't
try and sell it to them don't try and
get on the script straight away I know
the scripts there for a reason
but you need to exhaust the options
first that make sense you know you know
I'm my biggest tip I'll give anyone for
lease options that person has to know
like and trust you right so don't don't
try and do anything until you've got
that until you've got that that some
sort of trust from them that you're not
gonna rip them off
now remember lease options are that what
a little i-5 know that there are blank
bit of paper it's got lines on do you
see what I've got to put up with all
right listen
they're a blank it's a blank sheet of
paper so whenever you're doing it it
should always be so that it works for
you and it works for them it should
never just walk for you never just
always be what for you work for them
yeah so yeah hope that helps but just
get used to the script
yeah a bit more confident at ER and just
keep plugging because it will come just
be yourself yeah just be natural just
going through real estate to be police
option areas but is it what the you know
contact agent and being honest sit down
watch oh yeah thanks
thank you yes should be good okay
I will come over to this side of the
minute this sides not been getting many
questions to a 16 year old that was
involved in property what advice would I
give I would say you've got a lot of
time to educate yourself you've been on
the crash course sure get on the crash
course stop reading books there's so
much start hanging around people go to
the networking events hanging around
people that doing it they say don't know
that you are the some of the five people
you spend the most time with I actually
talked about this on last week's show
but I'll mention again it's a live
audience a but one of the interesting
things about that you all know that
saying yeah you all just some of the
five people that use Jim Rohn Jim Owen
that said that and you we always think
that that means like your best mates of
people you're physically with but we
live in like a social world where you
can hang out with people maybe not even
physically Samuel does a youtube video
every single day yeah you can watch that
and you're kind of hanging out with
Samuel
you can watch the podcast you can hang
out with us so I would say put yourself
in the right environment environment is
key read the books learn you know you're
16 you probably won't do any deals right
now but Samuel start where he was set
for his first thousand seventeen so I
would spend time now and and then just
start taking action yeah and you've gone
do you know what's brilliant I is I
think is they don't hear younger than 16
okay so the young youngest person in the
room we didn't give her a clap we got
this bad man yeah
so what's brilliant is I can bet by a
show of hands who wishes that they were
16 and knew what they knew that yeah
alright so most people who wishes they
were 16 most people in this room wishes
they knew what then you know then sort
educate you need to get out there needed
to educate and start hanging around
people that are successful and start
hanging around people that are doing it
and don't care what your friends think
ditch them get rid of it
if you've got negative people around you
get them out to get them out of your
life start hanging around with positive
people and just get out there and
educate get along to all the three
events crash course everything and start
educating because if you want to do this
now at sixteen imagine what you can be
like at 20 you're a powerful lady get
out there and start learning so DQ
universities are the countries that will
locate any deals with us we did talk a
little to be fair have way of you must
in Scotland at all now why would you so
it out however we did talk about this we
looked at some of the best places in
Europe to invest I'm trying to remember
this yeah was Portugal or River was one
of them and no no do you know the best
place in Europe to him or the best place
I've said England to invest gone Dublin
its doubling in value every year he's
actually Dublin Dublin is actually one
of the best places you've done that joke
and a podcast yeah we're either they was
fun
hey it was funny we we don't at the
minute but after our recent trip to
America with I was out in America with
Samuel there's a lot of possibilities
out there there is a lot a lot so I
potentially will be invest in America in
the next five years
what about you
thinking Joey's CEO like Germany yeah I
do
we might we get people we get people
that come to the crash girls from
Germany that apply these strategies over
and over in Germany I've got family over
in Germany as well so Germany was
somewhere I would potentially look at
yeah I see myself as an immigrant so I
know a lot of people are going to
generally if they're not coming near me
so I think it's a good market there yeah
it's good marketer an interesting way a
lot of I deal with a lot of overseas and
bases and they're not based in their own
countries then invest in UK yeah I don't
know why and they're not comfortable
investing in all countries of it MINURSO
they want to invest in you things to see
is a booming market I think it is ok
jeiza bread is basically Chinese agent
investors they love the UK the minute
they love it
I've got more Chinese investors buying
off me than ever hope that helps thank
you for your question you're right
[Applause]
the guy doing that and they all doing
that oh no two fingers up
you've got to yeah yeah no no no no no
the guy behind you go do your nails did
everyone just change what doing that we
guys it's time to know hey man how do
you buy so confession when you are so he
talks about having investors and you
know people that be viable disappear so
any just storing how do you actually buy
people to invest with you to allow you
to scale and also you have a say like a
full-time job way they paid and your
returns from your investment is not
making enough money I mean one point you
made
great what would you watch watching it's
off switch well we we talked about how
about leaving your job or what point you
do we actually disagreed yeah we
disagreed really so well I think you
should do is I think you should stay in
your song as long as you don't if you
hate your job is making you depress and
get out of it as long as your job is
okay
I think do it in your spare time build
the income up and slowly cut your hours
down until rappers replace your job in
there and then leave Alastair thinks
that you should just if you made a
decision that you want to invest in
property just quit your job and just go
for it and that's what he did me to
explain that long right if right well
what's your end was talking to this yeah
and I'm trying to lean in but I like to
look and so what was what do you want to
do with with your business what you do
with what you want to do with property
and so just to help you try it right
okay so have you I need investment
properties yes I have any free okay so
you're already on your way so the how
much what passive income do you get from
them from them but investment or please
roughly about maybe seventy thank us
okay so how much you come up
same house gone right okay what do you
do for a living my contractor right okay
so you're on decent money could that
between a half and me could you survive
McLean have fun yes right okay so you
are in a position where you believe you
talk that way oh that's fine I've got
that's all I'm asking yes can you could
you survive enough to be enough that
much yes right so you could leave your
job yes right but do you know what will
happen when you don't have a rose do you
work for a week okay it's a part-time
okay
so Luke when you leave your job you're
gonna suddenly get all this free time
and use that free time wisely so like
when I when I was looking getting
property I hated what I was doing
and I know I'm gonna be successful it's
in here I have a burning desire in here
that I am going to be successful no
matter what happens I wrote a book
called whatever it takes because I'm
gonna do whatever it takes
yeah so if you have that burning desire
new job is holding you back
leave your job I truly believe that if
you genuinely believe you're gonna meet
this if you're half-hearted at it you're
only going to get half hearted results
if you're fully committed you're gonna
get feeling committed results it's not
for everybody leaving the job because
some people aren't fully committed to
tell themselves they're other than not
because when the [ __ ] hits the fan are
you still going to be committed or you
can be calling back to your job what was
it do you
yes yes okay there's ways around
everything if you genuinely want to do
this you will do it you'll find a way
you'll either find you know successful
people have reasons or results they
don't have both so if you if you
genuinely want to do this and you
genuinely want to kill it in property
you will find a way and if that means
when you welcome two days a week in your
IT contractor and I'm in three days of
property then you will so when I first
started I gradually done it and then I
am done I went down I gave myself a
couple days and then I said
Hilda killed the job wolf soon as I
started making them literally
I sold make my first deal and I'm like I
made more money in two days and hold
that didn't the whole month suddenly now
on me I'm selling 12 to 15 he was a
month making 30 to 40 thousand pound a
month I wouldn't be able to do that
without a job how important is your job
to you man because of a minute all you
doing is you meeting some Dale fridge
that's my belief
it might not you might not agree with
that I don't totally goodness he doesn't
agree but do you know what it doesn't
matter it's my belief that you can
listen to me see why I don't totally
agree me it depends on what you want to
do right but a lot of people love their
job yeah right so if you love your job
and you you mean you you're already
financially free because you could live
off three and a half grand a month and
you're getting that passive income
anyway so what you want to do if you
love being an arty contractor yeah but
that's different that's if you love you
too much brilliant and you love your job
but if you're gonna use your job as an
excuse for not being successful in
property but you want to be successful
oh he is I'm not saying he's not not
saying it's not but I'm talking about
people in general I hear this all the
time people in general blaming the job
for the lack of success and it is okay
not you I'm just I mean in general get
out a lot if you love your job and you
enjoy what you do then do that yeah
because at the end of the day the voice
that alastair just gave you was to go
set up a deal selling business which is
guess what not everyone's cup of tea
it's another job a job that you might
not like doing you gonna want to do
you're gonna what we're designed to work
that's what we designed to do all right
some people would like to go sit on a
beach I want to work I want to do a job
so if you enjoy what you do
it's important that you enjoy we do
could you spare my sheet I'm doing if
you love being IT director do that do
you property on the side as an
investment that's fine it is you want to
do less hours and do more on property
could you love that as well and do that
you can't really he can't really go
wrong but I would I never would push
someone to leave their job and say you
making someone else rich I like you know
I don't need it just say that but I
don't look I don't know I don't believe
that's not for everybody but you know
what I get so many people messaging me
and saying Luke they're stuck in a day
there then it's like yeah it's so
frustrating because they're complaining
they're working 60 70 hours a week but
then they haven't got they don't give
themselves that the time to develop
their own business
it's actually really depressing because
the reality is not and I'm not referring
to you I'm just referring to a lot of
the messages my experience the people
all the duties that work in a job and
they're not working on their business I
was always told mind your own business
as opposed to somebody else's business
so look I'm not referring to you and if
you love your job man I'd really love
that I hated my job I hated it and to be
in a position where you love your job is
phenomenal so the answer to question is
yes lever job and staying job at the
same time frame I do bands okay one last
one and then we're never going after
looking after me want one last one was
gonna give her the most excited come on
man oh she's very excited yeah go on
stand up stand up
sorry guys she's just more excited than
you this better be a good one now that
the pressure is because they want is
they want is the questions
[Applause]
[Laughter]
because I know for a fact this so many
well I've got brilliant news for you
straight off a 30-day rule
it's a 90-day rule already three times
better off than you were a second ago
yeah it's a 90-day rule it's not 30 days
yeah so it means you can have a sense on
this for 90 days and suppose 30 days oh
yes two ways there's a legal way and an
illegal way the legal way okay well
we'll tell you their legal way when the
cameras come okay there's no such thing
where the cameras go all right there's
no legal way you can change right you've
got to apply the counsel change you use
from the property if you get the change
of use you can do it right now that's
the legal way the illegal way which I
really highly recommend you shouldn't do
what people do and seriously you really
shouldn't do this but if you did do it
this is what you do you could you people
people do cuz it's 90 days is they put
four different ads up on like Airbnb in
countries with different pictures of the
set of the same property and then they
rent that out for three months that one
out for three bids are actually the same
however is Lee easily is illegal and if
you get caught it's a 20 gram juma fine
do you remember in a podcast Madonna no
do it
remember that fine that and that news
article we've done a kind of an it will
be ridiculous it's not many rules but
the ones that are there don't break them
because they find
it was like 70,000 pound fine it was a
massive fine the person go for break in
the rule which got caught so anyway but
the best way around it the really best
way around it is to not do it in London
find somewhere else that works because
there's plenty of places all do it for
90 days it was three times better than
you thought it was a minute ago
you're already three times bare off so
we should have made your day but you
look very disappointed you are a happy
face no problem her hands
[Applause]
[Applause]
Oh